desde el aire se pueden ver las columnas
de humo en la sierra bermeja en málaga
que sigue envuelta en llamas el incendio
que comenzó el miércoles se ha visto
empeorado por los fuertes vientos de
este fin de semana en la región ya se ha
cobrado la vida de al menos un bombero y
obligado a la evacuación de miles de
personas algunos de edad avanzada por lo
que se han tenido que habilitar centros
de emergencia con voluntarios y aquí
estamos
a la espera de ver cuándo podemos
regresar a nuestra casa para contener
las llamas el gobierno central desplegó
al ejército que se unió a los casi 400
bomberos movilizados en la zona en medio
de las críticas al ejecutivo regional
por la falta de operativos su poder es
controlado realmente descontrola no hay
más que ver los focos por todas partes y
lo sinceramente es que poca gente
los equipos de rescate han advertido que
todavía están lejos de controlar el
fuego que según las investigaciones
iniciales habría sido provocado una
situación recurrente en el sur de europa
durante los secos meses de verano aunque
este año la zona del mediterráneo ha
sido golpeada por varios incendios
debido a la ola de calor